Season Four
of Stranger Things
arrives on Netflix
later this year.
But how has the cast been
keeping themselves busy
in the gap between seasons?
Voice acting, music videos,
Netflix Originals,
Hollywood blockbusters,
you name it?
Here's what the kids
from Stranger things
have been up to.
Millie Bobby Brown,
who plays
the psychokinetically
gifted Eleven,
starred in stacks
of high-profile productions
between seasons
of Stranger Things.
Most notably, she played the
title role in Enola Holmes,
a 2020
Netflix Original mystery
based on the books
by Nancy Springer.
In case
you somehow missed it,
it's a sassy,
energetic spin-off
from the classic stories
by Arthur Conan Doyle,
which details the adventures
of Holmes'
lesser-known little sister.
A second Enola Holmes film
is in post-production,
with Bobby Brown returning
alongside Louis Partridge.
Millie also found time
to feature
in 2019's Godzilla:
King of the Monsters
and in the 2021 sequel,
Godzilla vs. Kong,
and there are
other interesting roles
on the horizon.
She'll star in
and executive produce
2023's Damsel,
another Netflix Original
that subverts
the damsel-in-distress trope
and sees Bobby Brown's
Princess Elodie
taking on a dragon rather
than waiting to be rescued.
Seems Eleven's not
the only one capable
of laying the smack down
on terrifying monsters.
Finn Wolfhard,
who plays Mike Wheeler,
has likewise been
keeping himself active
with some
high-profile releases.
In 2017's It,
he played the younger
version of Richie Tozier
in this chilling adaptation
of the Stephen King novel.
And more recently,
he starred
in 2021's
Ghostbusters: Afterlife,
a follow-up to
the Ivan Reitman originals
directed and co-written
by his son Jason.
In it, Finn plays
Trevor Spengler,
grandson of the late
Harold Ramis's Egon,
who gets to live out our
collective childhood dream
of driving Ecto-1.
It's a significant step up
from a pushbike
and a Peter Venkman outfit.
-Why are you Venkman?
-Because I'm Venkman.
No, I'm Venkman.
Alongside big-budget
Hollywood sequels,
Wolfhard has done
plenty of voice work,
including Carmen Sandiego,
in which he features
as Player,
a teenage hacker
based on the unseen
live-action character
from the original
1994 animated series
Where on Earth
is Carmen Sandiego?
He also added
to his horror credentials
by voicing the sinister
Pugsley Addams
in 2019's The Addams Family,
and he provided the voice
of Boypunzel
in JJ Villard's Fairy Tales.
Really? I didn't know that.
More voice work
is on the horizon for 2022
in Pinocchio,
in which he plays Lampwick,
as well as
The Legend of Ochi.
He'll also star as Ziggy
in 2022's When You Finish
Saving The World,
Jesse Eisenberg's
directorial debut.
Next we have
Gaten Matarazzo,
who plays Dustin,
everyone's favourite
Demodog-raising
Neverending Story
duetting superstar.
Beautiful.
Like the rest of the cast,
Gaten has loads of stuff
on the go.
He produces
Prank Encounters,
a horror-themed hidden
camera show on Netflix,
and, like Finn Wolfhard,
he's been doing plenty
of VO work.
He voiced Bubba in 2019's
The Angry Birds Movie 2
and he'll play
the role of Ramy
in the 2022
animated feature Hump.
Matarazzo also made
a cameo appearance
as Casey the Electrician
in Michelle Obama's adorable
cooking show for kids
Waffles + Mochi.
That's umami.
-Umami!
-What about my mummy?
He also uses his fame
to raise awareness
about his condition,
cleidocranial dysplasia,
as well as fundraising
for non-profit organisation
CCD Smiles.
Caleb McLaughlin plays Lucas
in Stranger Things,
the most pragmatic member
of the group
and undisputed master
of the wrist rocket.
Like his co-stars,
he's been super proactive.
He made his Hollywood debut
in 2020's Concrete Cowboy,
directed by Ricky Staub
and based on the novel
Ghetto Cowboy by Greg Neri.
In it,
McLaughlin stars as Cole,
a Detroit teenager
sent to live
with his estranged father
Harp played by Idris Elba.
-I'm your father.
-You ain't my father!
McLaughlin's performance
drew praise,
and the story is based
on the real urban
African American
horse riding culture
of Philadelphia,
specifically the Fletcher
Street Urban Riding Club.
In 2019, McLaughlin appeared
in Steven Soderbergh's
High Flying Bird,
a sports drama detailing
the world of pro basketball,
and he's also done
plenty of voice work.
Featuring as young Gary
in Final Space,
Ghost the Boy
in Summer Camp Island,
and Trevor Johnson
in Ultra City Smiths.
Noah Schnapp plays Will,
perhaps the most complex
and troubled member
of the party.
A huge chunk of
his childhood goes missing
and he spends a week
in the Upside Down
being hunted
by the Demogorgon.
In 2018,
he played nine-year-old
crossword fanatic Otis
in Donal Lardner Ward's
drama
We Only Know So Much.
And a year later he landed
the lead role in Abe,
a comedy about a boy
who grows tired
of mealtime arguments
and tries to reunite
his estranged
half-Israeli,
half-Palestinian family
via the medium of cooking.
2020 saw him feature
in period drama
Waiting for Anya,
in which he played Jo,
a 13-year-old shepherd
helping smuggle
Jewish children into Spain
in an adaptation
of Michael Morpurgo's
popular young adult novel
of the same name.
You're a monster!
And as if to prove
how versatile he is,
Noah also featured
in 2020 comedy horror
Hubie Halloween
alongside none other
than Adam Sandler.
Ghost, scary,
but also the key
to Halloween safety.
You'll know Sadie Sink
as tomboy Max,
the skateboarding,
Dig Dug-destroying outsider
who captures the hearts
of Dustin and Lucas
in Season 2.
Aside from internet-breaking
Taylor Swift videos,
her most recent appearance
was in
Leigh Janiak's Fear Street.
She played Ziggy Berman
in Part 2 of the trilogy,
cementing her horror movie
final girl status
in this bloody homage
to 70's horror.
It wasn't her first foray
into the genre.
In 2019, she appeared
as teenage nurse Haley
-in Ciaran Foy's Eli…
-Boo!
…a movie about
an autoimmune deficient boy
receiving care in a secluded
and sinister
medical facility.
Looking ahead, Sadie
will play the lead role
in 9/11 drama Dear Zoe,
as well as Ellie
in forthcoming
Darren Aronofsky comedy
The Whale.
That's not all.
Sink is a vegan
and passionate
animal welfare activist.
And in 2018,
she collaborated
with the likes
of Rooney Mara,
Joaquin Phoenix
and Sia in Dominion,
an animal rights documentary
from Chris Delforce,
a performance
that would land her
an Award of Excellence
for Narration
from the Hollywood
International
Independent
Documentary Awards.
Priah Ferguson's
performance of Erica,
Lucas's take-no-prisoners
younger sister,
made her the breakout star
of Stranger Things Season 3.
The scourge of Scoops Ahoy's
free ice cream policy
and frequent tormentor
of Steve Harrington.
More fudge, please.
And if you want to see
more of her,
Priah appeared
in 2018's The Oath,
a political comedy
about a family
trying to survive a cursed
Thanksgiving weekend.
Looking ahead,
Priah is set to star
in Netflix's animated series
My Dad the Bounty Hunter
and Marlon Wayans-produced
Halloween movie Boo.
Can I try
the peppermint stick?
Haven't you already tried
Yes, and I'd like
to try it again.
So that's what
the increasingly
inaccurately named
Stranger Things kids
have been up to recently.
Who are you most excited to
reconnect with in Season 4?
Let us know in the comments,
and remember to subscribe
to Still Watching Netflix
for more videos about your
favourite shows and movies.